you were saying that in 2007 there was a
moment where you were almost trading for
kobe yeah i thought it was done
please tell me that story so
um
i was in dancing with the stars and
we practiced a lot like seven eight
hours a day because i needed it and
there was i was going back and forth
with um dr bus
and he had i forget who called who i
think he called me actually and said
look we think we might be partying ways
with kobe and there i remember it
vividly because there was a pa named
elvis who was working as it was just
lakers lakers lakers lakers lakers i
used to give him a hard time he'd give
me a hard time and we had just gone to
the finals the year before and this and
that and so um
we just talked kobe and he was kobe kobe
kobe all the time you know the guy kobe
you know and um
so it started to happen
and
i started telling him about it and that
was the kiss of death because the minute
i told elvis
it all fell apart oh no why did it fall
apart because i guess mitch kupchak
taught kobe into stain you know it was
just like deandre not the same same but
yeah
when a guy that's key to your team wants
to leave you're gonna do everything you
can to keep them so what would this like
kobe maps team have looked like um it
would have been damn good yeah you know
and dirk was like i would have traded me
for kobe and i'm like no i'm not gonna
trade you dirk that's the whole point
right wow yeah we would have been
something else and it's crazy to just
think about all the things that would
have changed if that trade you just
never know yeah
wow oh my gosh then they trade for paul
gasol and
life's different it's just the nba
you're just one you know sprained ankle
or trade or who knows what and
everything changes yeah but like when
you say you were close you're like we
were at the finish line
i thought it was done yeah like
it's done 2007 kobe's coming done like
let's start talking about putting
together the trade call
wow